mes chers collègues bien le bonjour à
toutes et tous
alors notre ordre du jour appelle
l'examen du rapport adopté hier par la
mission d'évaluation
de la loi numéro 20
16-87 du 2 février 2016 créant de
nouveaux droits en faveur des malades et
des personnes en fin de vie notre
commission se doit d'être au rendez-vous
de ce grand débat de société qui
interroge nos convictions les plus
intimes il nous revient en particulier
de tenter d'objectiver au maximum le
débat
cela passe d'abord par cette évaluation
de la loi classe Leonetti qu'il revient
au premier chef au Parlement bien sûr de
réaliser avant de savoir s'il faut à
nouveau légiférer sur le sujet il nous
faut bien sûr au préalable évaluer la
législation en vigueur
par ailleurs nous attendons d'ici
quelques semaines la remise des travaux
que nous avons demandé à la Cour des
comptes sur la question cruciale des
soins palliatifs la Commission avait
confié à la mission d'évaluation un
objectif précis mené à bien cette
évaluation d'ici la fin du mois de mars
au regard de la progression parallèle
des travaux de la convention citoyenne
je veux donc remercier vivement le
président les rapporteurs et les membres
de la mission qui se sont parfaitement
acquittés de leur tâches non seulement
en termes de calendrier mais en
procédant à une analyse approfondie
fondée sur de nombreux auditions et
plusieurs déplacements ce travail
comporte une partie plus prospective
avec de nombreuses recommandations
chacun en conscience pourra y adhérer ou
non bien sûr et c'est pourquoi il a été
prévu à titre exceptionnel que chaque
membre de la mission s'il le souhaite
pourra présenter une contribution écrite
qui sera jointes au rapport de la
mission on avait effectivement décidé
cela bien en amont sans plus tarder donc
je vais passer la parole au président
puis au rapporteur monsieur le Président
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
bonjour à toutes et à tous chers
collègues
je vais vous dire tout d'abord le très
grand plaisir que j'ai eu à travailler
sur cette mission
c'est un sujet passionnant la fin de vie
c'est un sujet qui intéresse les
Français tous les Français parce que ils
sont évidemment tous concernés d'une
façon ou d'une autre
grand plaisir aussi parce que nous avons
su travailler je crois dans le cadre de
cette mission qui je le rappelle
dans le cadre de cette commission des
affaires sociales réunissait 19
collègues des 10 groupes parlementaires
représentés à l'Assemblée nationale
et nous avons su travailler dans un
climat serein apaisé
respectueux je dois avouer que ça nous
faisait du bien dans le cadre du tumulte
qui en parallèle
saisissaient notre hémicycle c'était
c'était très agréable de pouvoir avoir
ces moments de réflexion de fond et nous
avons essayé avec mes collègues qu'on
rapporteurs Caroline et Didier d'avoir
la vision la plus large possible de
cette question de l'accompagnement de la
fin de vie dans le sens où la fin de vie
évidemment est un sujet de société qui
recoupe beaucoup de domaines
c'est évidemment un sujet médical mais
pas que c'est aussi et peut-être d'abord
une question
philosophique éthique juridique
puisqu'il s'agissait d'évaluer la loi et
nous avons mené j'allais dire tambour
battant ce travail j'ai eu l'occasion de
présider de nombreuses commissions
d'enquêtes parlementaires qui duraient
six mois cette mission elle
devait rendre ses travaux au bout de
trois mois c'est c'est logique et en
moins de trois mois nous avons mené
presque autant d'audition que que
j'avais pu le faire dans d'autres
présidents de commission d'enquête en 6
mois nous avons mené 31 auditions
avec une très grande diversité d'acteurs
concernés par le sujet nous avons fait
des déplacements
pour le contexte évidemment ne nous a
pas permis de faire tous les
déplacements que nous aurions souhaité
mais par contre nous avons eu des
retours et des députés qui
qui nous ont fait des retours de terrain
des députés de la mission et nous nous
sommes rendus malgré tout dans de
nombreuses établissements médicaux que
ce soit en unité de soins palliatifs
dans des structures hospitalières nous
avons rencontré évidemment des soignants
des
des passions
et ça a été un moment très fort cette
rencontre avec les patients en fin de
vie et aussi les familles qui n'étaient
pas moins forts comme comme rencontre et
comme comme échange
donc voilà le cadre dans lequel nous
avons travaillé vous le savez on est
dans un contexte en plus qui fait de la
fin de vie un vrai sujet dans le débat
public il y a eu le comité d'éthique qui
s'est prononcé en septembre et nous
avons travaillé en parallèle de la
convention citoyenne qui doit rendre son
avis dimanche
voilà les le contexte général et je suis
heureux aussi que ce texte a été adopté
hier à l'unanimité par les membres de la
mission et je veux je veux aussi saluer
nos trois administrateurs
qui ont travaillé à nos côtés d'une
façon absolument remarquable et je veux
les citer Alix de Roubin Adrien Laurent
et Jérémy kaloa qui ont fait vraiment un
travail exceptionnel parce que c'est
vrai que nous étions limités dans le
temps et je pense que le rapport que
nous vous proposons et riche et complet
alors je ne vais pas être beaucoup plus
long simplement pour vous dire que cette
mission elle a répondu au cahier des
charges qui nous étaient assignés c'est
à dire d'évaluer cette loi
cette loi elle a 7 ans d'âge et elle n'a
jamais été évaluée par le Parlement ce
qui n'est pas normal
nous avons eu des difficultés pour
obtenir des données quantitatives sur un
certain nombre d'aspects cette loi
évidemment elle affirme un certain
nombre de principes le premier principe
c'est dans le texte laisse Leonetti
c'est le droit à une fin de vie digne le
deuxième principe c'est le refus de
l'obstination des raisonnable le
troisième principe c'est l'accès aux
soins palliatifs pour tous et afin
d'obtenir d'arriver à ces principes il y
avait trois notions fondamentales que
nous avons évaluées c'est
le caractère le renforcement du
caractère contraignant
des directives anticipées
le renforcement du rôle de la personne
de confiance et la mise en place de la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès donc ce sont ces trois notions que
nous avons abordées que nous avons
j'allais dire presque 10 séqués et que
nous allons vous présenter
je dois vous dire que globalement
sur ces trois aspects sur la question
des soins palliatifs on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la situation n'est pas
satisfaisante il y a une offre de soins
palliatifs insuffisante sur les droits
des patients à travers les directives
anticipées et la personne de confiance
ce sont de réelles avancées des avancées
fortes mais qui sont très limitées dans
les faits
et sur le dernier point sur la sur la
sédation profonde et continue on
s'aperçoit que c'était une évolution
législative importante mais qu'elle est
très peu utilisé voilà dernier point
parce que je ne peux pas ne pas
l'évoquer même si ça n'était pas dans
notre cahier des charges et ça n'est pas
dans notre rapport puisque notre rapport
ne prend pas position sur la question de
l'aide active à mourir il n'y a pas de
prise de position
en revanche je dois vous dire que nous
avons fait 31 auditions nous n'avons pas
posé une seule question sur les actives
à mourir et toutes les auditions tous
les interlocuteurs nous en ont parlé
voilà donc je le mets au débat alors ils
nous ont parlé avec des avis différents
évidemment mais ça a été un sujet je
dois vous le dire qui a été spontanément
abordé par tous nos interlocuteurs mais
ça n'était pas l'objet de cette mission
et nous vous proposons aujourd'hui une
évaluation de la loi actuelle de la loi
klessonetti qui contribuera je l'espère
au débat public qui continuera notamment
dimanche avec la vie de la convention
citoyenne et si j'ai bien compris la
réception de cette convention citoyenne
par le Président de la République lundi
prochain
voilà merci cher collègue et je laisse
la parole alors je ne sais pas qui
commence de Caroline et Didier merci
Monsieur merci madame la Présidente
merci
et bien je vais passer la parole à nos
rapporteurs et ils se sont mis d'accord
donc je commence par Didier Martin
merci madame la Présidente à mon tour je
voudrais adresser des remerciements
au président de la mission qui a su
maîtriser le temps et maîtriser le sujet
et donc et qui s'est beaucoup impliqué
lui-même tel un rapporteur dans ce
dossier on peut le dire c'est la vérité
remercier tous les collègues aussi de la
mission qui sont venus comme ils le
pouvaient c'est vrai que c'était danse
c'était beaucoup d'horaires mais
qui sont tous venus au moins une fois
remercier aussi toutes les personnes
auditionnées qui ont répondu à nos
invitations et puis
remercier évidemment les administrateurs
qui vous livrent un document qu'on a
terminé qu'on a fait voter par la
Mission hier je
présente un peu nos excuses pour les
cours délais entre la transmission du
rapport et cette commission
c'est imposée par le calendrier de notre
commission ça peut engendrer des
frustrations mais ce rapport n'est
qu'une étape
et il mérite d'être travaillé tous
ensemble ce matin discuter ce matin bien
sûr et il y aura une suite que ce soit
les soins palliatifs que ce soit aussi
des situations de toute fin de vie que
le président a évoqué en particulier
lorsque le patient est inconscient on
doit prendre ses directives anticipées
discuter avec la personne de confiance
et prendre une décision collégiale pour
la mise en place de cette sédation
je voudrais dire aussi dans un propos
introductif que
relisez des cinq premiers articles de la
loi ils sont essentiels ils sont
fondamentaux
on y aborde les principes forts je cite
par exemple la volonté du patient la
dignité l'apaisement de toutes les
souffrances le rôle des soins palliatifs
et donc les législateurs je me rends
compte maintenant au moment de présenter
ce rapport ont abordé le sujet sous cet
angle là puisqu'il s'agissait de droit
et de devoir et d'obligation de la part
des équipes soignantes de respecter
certains principes et ces cinq premiers
articles sont fondamentaux
on y revient un peu à l'article 8 sur
les directives anticipées on y revient
un peu sur la personne de confiance à
l'article 9 sur la volonté du patient
l'article 10 et puis il y a trois autres
articles qui évoquent le principe de
nos travaux dans le domaine bioéthique
avec l'OPEX et la Commission nationale
du débat public
les cinq premiers articles je le répète
sont sur le sujet que le président
abordé et qui a été l'essentiel de nos
travaux
une limite quelques limites à nos
travaux premièrement la limite du temps
et la limite du déplacement
je suis persuadé que nous tous on serait
désireux de faire de nouveaux
déplacements pour rencontrer les acteurs
parce que les témoignages que nous avons
recueillis sur le terrain sont
absolument fondamentaux
limite aussi par le fait que dans la loi
on parle beaucoup des inscriptions dans
le dossier médical du patient or il nous
est impossible d'avoir accès à ce
dossier médical
c'est évident donc nous avons une
recommandation sur le sujet pour que une
lecture anonisée bien entendu et
statistiques de ce qu'il se fait en
pratique dans les unités puissent être
évaluée sous l'angle administratif et
aussi législatif
nous avons fait en sorte que nous
puissions recueillir des éléments sur
ces dossiers médicaux et puis nous avons
eu
un peu le dilemme d'aborder ce rapport à
la fois sous l'oeil du législateur qui
porte un regard sur le travail d'autres
législateurs et non des moindres ils ont
laissé leur nom et puis de l'aborder en
particulier Caroline et moi-même sous
l'angle du soignant
du soignant qui se voit dans la peau de
ceux qui sont au chevet et de ceux qui
prennent les décisions et qui les
mettent en oeuvre et cela a été
évidemment un enrichissement important
aussi pour notre propre réflexion et je
tenais à le souligner
avant de
céder la parole
je vais le faire tout de suite à
Caroline si on veut bien
évoquer je voudrais juste évoquer le
plan de notre de notre rapport qui
aborde dans un premier temps les soins
palliatifs et c'est Caroline qui va vous
en parler madame la députée et ensuite
nous aborderons les directives
anticipées la personne de confiance et
de la sédation profonde continue sachant
que nous allons plutôt faire un duo que
de se partager strictement les tâches
donc bonjour à toutes et à tous comme ça
vous a été dit donc le rapport que nous
proposons est composé de trois grandes
parties
l'accès aux soins palliatifs les
directives anticipées la personne de
confiance et la sédation profonde des
contenus
je vais surtout concentrer mon propos
sur l'accès aux soins palliatifs qui est
au cœur de la loi classique leetti et de
façon plus générale des lois sur la fin
de vie les soins palliatifs sont apparus
dans les années 80 en France et ont été
développés dans le cadre de cinq plans
nationaux dans le dernier a été lancé en
2021 consacré par le législateur en 1999
le droit d'accéder aux soins palliatifs
a été raffermé par la loi classique
selon son article premier les malades
ont le droit d'avoir une fin de vie
digne et accompagnée du meilleur
apaisement possible de la souffrance
fin 2021 la France disposée de
7546 liés hospitaliers en soins
palliatifs dont 1990 en unité de son
palliatifs répartie dans 171 unités de
soins palliatifs et 5566 bi identifiés
de soins palliatifs situés dans 904
établissements et on compte 420 équipes
mobiles la cartographie des soins
palliatifs et cependant marqués par des
disparités territoriales 21 départements
ne disposent pas d'unité de soins
palliatifs ce constat questionne donc
effectivement
palliatifs nombreuses ont été les
personnes auditionnées à indiquer que
deux tiers des malades nécessitant des
soins palliatifs il n'y avait pas accès
en l'absence de données robustes la
mission n'a pas été en mesure d'évaluer
précisément l'écart entre l'offre et les
besoins soin palliatifs nous
recommandons donc de mesurer précisément
ses besoins afin d'objectiver la mission
la situation en revanche il est certain
que compte tenu de l'évolution de la
démographie française il est
indispensable de continuer à développer
massivement mes soins palliatifs afin
que les droits des malades prévus par la
loi soit pleinement garanties partout en
France cela suppose de rendre plus
attractive cette filière qui est
affectée par la pénurie de soignants il
manque aujourd'hui plus de 100 médecins
dans les structures de soins palliatifs
existantes et il faudrait former au
moins 300 médecins Sans palliatifs dans
les quatre années à venir vous
renouveler les équipes actuelles
puisqu’un cinquième des praticiens en
poste devraient prendre leur retraite
d'ici 5 ans il y a donc urgence
à titre d'exemple à l'USP de Juvisy qui
dispose de Dily un des deux postes de
praticien hospitalier vacantes depuis
2018 et la seule médecin présente y
exerce un temps partiel nous proposons
donc de lancer une grande campagne de
recrutement et de valorisation des
métiers du secteur des soins palliatifs
la pénurie de médecins ne doit pas
masquer l'ampleur des manques puisque
c'est bien l'ensemble du système de
santé qui est actuellement sous tension
je crois que je ne vous apprends rien
cette situation complique l'accès aux
soins palliatifs à domicile tout
particulièrement y compris un
établissement médico-sociaux dans un
contexte d'évolution de Love dans avec
la disparition des réseaux de soins
palliatifs bien que publicité par les
Français le maintien à domicile peut
s'avérer compliqué au regard des
implications d'une prise en charge
paléative en particulier pour les
proches aidants
un ehpad les équipes ne sont pas
toujours en mesure de faire face aux
situations de fin de vie lors de son
audition le professeur Régis Soubré nous
indiquait que 1500 résidents des pâtes
sont transférés à l'hôpital chaque année
et meurt dans un délai de deux heures
suivant leur arrivée il est aussi apparu
que les modalités de financement du
système de santé sont peu adaptés à la
qualité de la prise en charge palliative
que ce soit en ville ou à l'hôpital
ainsi la tarification à l'activité la
fameuse T2A valorise mal les soins
palliatifs qui reposent moins sur des
actes techniques que sur un
accompagnement humain pire la T2A peut
favoriser des pratiques conduisant de
l'obstination déraisonnable dans les
services curatifs alors même que les
soins palliatifs apporteraient une
meilleure réponse aux besoins des
malades
il faut donc revoir le modèle de
financement des soins palliatifs en
remettant en cause le modèle actuel de
la T2A et en faisant évoluer le
financement des soins palliatifs
hospitaliers vers un modèle mixte
alliant une part forfaitaire et une part
liée à l'activité il faut également
assurer la traçabilité des moyens
financiers alloués aux soins palliatifs
au sein des établissements hospitaliers
et élargir la prise en charge des
consultations à domicile pour faciliter
les consultations longues dans le cadre
de l'accompagnement palliatif et
permettent à des professionnels comme
les ergothérapeutes ou les psychologues
n'intervenir plus facilement à domicile
par ailleurs la mort est souvent
envisagée sous l'angle de l'échec
thérapeutique et les soins palliatifs
sont relégués à la gestion de la mort
alors même que les prises en charge
curatives et paléatives doivent être
menées conjointement
une forte est tentée étanchéité perdure
dans les soins curatifs et les soins
palliatifs une telle situation nuit à la
qualité de la prise en charge des
patients transférés parfois tardivement
en soins palliatifs il est donc
essentiel de mieux sensibiliser les
soignants aux soins palliatifs nous
souhaitons donc soit généralisé les
formations à la fin de vie à l'approche
palliatif pendant les études de des
professionnels de santé et pendant leur
carrière et conviendrait également de
développer la filière palliatif comme
discipline autonome en créant un diplôme
d'études spécialisée de médecine
palliative et en explorant la
possibilité de créer une spécialité
d'infirmière en soins palliatifs en
définitif c'est toute la culture
médicale qui doit évoluer et intégrer la
dimension palliative au cours du
parcours de soins du malade sans
atteindre nécessairement la fin de vie
voilà en résumé ce que je pouvais dire
sur les principaux constats que nous
avons établi s'agissant de l'accès aux
soins palliatifs et je passe désormais
la parole à Didier à Monsieur le Député
Martin
pour la suite des présentations du
rapport je reviendrai pour la conclusion
je prends la parole merci
vous avez donc dans la synthèse et
d'aller recommandations bon nombre de
recommandations concernant les soins
palliatifs
je voudrais rappeler que il existe une
définition officielle des soins
palliatifs et il n'y a pas d'imprécision
sur l'objet et l'objectif de ces soins
palliatifs c'est une définition
d'ailleurs qui reprend les définitions
internationales
je voudrais
souligner la question des unités mobiles
de soins palliatifs
nous avons visité une unité dans le sud
de l'Essonne et il est apparu que
le travail en unité mobile
s'effectuait dans de nombreux lieux
[Musique]
parce que les soins palliatifs
concernent tous les âges aussi et
concerne toutes les situations sociales
donc à domicile bien entendu dans un
domicile particulier qui est l'EHPAD
dans les masses dans les femmes dans les
IME dans les centres d'hébergement
précaires dans les centres de
réinsertion sociale et même chez les
gens du voyage donc c'est toutes ces
catégories de personnes qui sont
malheureusement confrontés à jour à une
question de fin de vie et les unités de
soins palliatifs doivent faire cette qui
ont été créés dans leur mobilité doivent
faire cette démarche d'aller vers
ce n'est pas sans
poser quelques difficultés parce qu'il
faut des dispositifs d'actions
coordonnées parce qu'il faut des
professionnels disponibles et parce
qu'il faut des professionnels rémunérés
pour se faire
j'y reviendrai sur le rôle important des
idées des infirmières diplômés d'état
qui sont quotidiennement au chevet de
ces patients qui soient
chez eux ou en hospitalisation à
domicile ou
un établissement ce sont ces infirmières
qui au quotidien recueillent
les renseignements pour orienter la
prise en charge des soins palliatifs
les les deux la deuxième partie de ces
de ce rapport concerne les directives
anticipées concernent la personne de
confiance et la sédation en fait cette
loi parle de la sédation profonde
continue maintenu jusqu'au décès
il existe d'autres formes de sédation
des sédations légères des sédations
proportionnées des sédations temporaires
et dans la loi on ne parle que de la
sédation profonde continue jusqu'au
décès donc un acte définitif formel
d'endormissement du patient avec
analgésie et arrêt de tous les
traitements y compris l'hydratation et
l'alimentation qui sont de par la loi
considérées comme des traitements
sur les directives anticipées
on a constaté que très peu de Français
avaient consigné des directives
anticipées par voie écrite parfois par
voie orale et il faut comprendre que
cette bonne idée du législateur et
malgré toute difficile à mettre en
oeuvre parce que quand on est vivant
bien portant et en activité on ne pense
pas à rédiger des directives anticipées
parce que quand on commence à être
malade on se bat contre la maladie avec
l'équipe soignante et on ne pense pas à
rédiger des directives anticipées donc
il y a une résistance naturelle à
exercer ce droit de rédiger des
directives anticipées
et on ne sait pas quoi mettre dans ces
directives alors la S a rédigé des
formulaires il existe des aides à cette
rédaction mais elles sont peu connues il
y a peu d'informations je mettrai sur le
même plan la question de la personne de
confiance
c'est un choix difficile à faire et
c'est un acte très difficile d'accepter
d'être personne de confiance
être personne de confiance pourquoi
faire et que décider le jour où le
patient ne sera plus en état d'exprimer
sa volonté en fonction de quoi on pourra
témoigner et témoigner de quoi
certains nous ont avoué que ils étaient
bien embêtés de se trouver en situation
de personnes de confiance
il faut être
équipé il faut être un peu formé il faut
être un peu guidé et nous avons une
recommandation pour aider à accomplir
cette tâche de devenir une personne de
confiance pour pour un autre
[Musique]
très peu de ces directives anticipées en
fait
bien qu'elle soit devenue contraignante
et pas opposable
sont d'actualité au moment la question
se pose et ça c'est un témoignage que
j'ai reçu d'un médecin on était soit
palliatifs
en fait tout se rediscute au dernier
moment donc les directives anticipées
sont utiles quand elles existent elles
peuvent elles peuvent aider l'équipe
à prendre des décisions mais il faut
savoir les interpréter par rapport à la
loi d'ailleurs le dit à l'urgence vitale
par rapport à la situation
donc il y a là une limite
nous proposons bien sûr de l'information
sur cette possibilité d'exercer son
droit à rédiger des directives
anticipées à choisir sa personne de
confiance mais nous savons qu'il ne
pourra pas y avoir 100% des Français en
situation d'avoir
rédigé leur directive anticipée et
choisit leur personne de confiance
quelque part d'un point de vue
intellectuel ce serait satisfaisant puis
ça rend service aussi aux équipes quand
la situation se présente mais
pratiquement il ne faut pas trop
surinvestir sur cette possibilité
offerte par les directives anticipées
utile mais rare finalement et qui ne
correspondront pas à toutes les
situations rencontrées donc révisables
en permanence donc
à bémol sur cette sur cet aspect là
deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est le grand apport de la loi
classe lyonneti à savoir la sédation
profonde continue jusqu'au dessert
cette disposition est particulièrement
utile parce que la pratique de la
sédation terminale autrefois
elle existait bien avant la loi
ça prenait d'autres noms que ce que la
loi a choisi mais ça s'appelait en
particulier le cocktail lytique et
on avait tendance à mettre en place
cette ce traitement ce soit et après on
ouvrait plus la porte de la chambre on
demandait où en est-on et c'est tout
là maintenant les choses sont claires
les choses sont claires grâce à la loi
et c'est l'utilité de la loi cette
sédation elle peut être mise en oeuvre
sur demande du patient c'est-à-dire un
patient conscient
qui exprime sa volonté et il faut que
cette volonté correspondent à son état
de santé et à son pronostic évidemment à
très court terme et un état de
souffrance qu'on ne peut pas calmer donc
le patient peut faire lui-même cette
demande et puis parfois le patient est
inconscient et ça arrive souvent en
réanimation faut bien le dire ou on
arrête la vie artificielle et on s'est
date les patients et on évite les signes
de douleur les signes de défense et on
adapte et on adapte le traitement pour
que effectivement surviennent le décès
sans avoir l'intention de donner la mort
ça c'est le principe sur lequel la loi
actuelle
est tout à fait formelle au moment où la
mise en place de la sédation de la part
des soignants il n'y a pas d'intention
de donner la mort mais bien l'intention
de soulager
y compris Monsieur Jean Leonetti
il y a effectivement un moment où la
situation dure et comme l'a dit aussi
Martine Lombard les équipes sont en face
d'un patient qui n'en finit pas de
mourir
et là effectivement et la famille aussi
souffre de cette de ce spectacle
ça peut être particulièrement
aussi difficile puisqu'on en a été les
témoins on a recueilli le témoignage en
situation néonatale où on met en place
une sédation pour des raisons évidemment
très précises et cette décision est tout
à fait fondée mais la sédation en
période natale dans le cas que nous
avons rencontré dure longtemps huit
jours nous attendit huit jours de
sédation
devant un nouveau-né qu'on alimente plus
qu'on hydrate plus
voilà je voulais partager au nom de nous
tous ce témoignage parce que il a
provoqué chez nous une
recommandation c'est que cette sédiation
doit être adaptée aux circonstances et à
la façon dont le patient réagit à cette
sédation qui doit être dans une
intention bien déterminée mais qui doit
aussi être adapté aux circonstances
rencontrer lors de la mise en place
c'est vrai que tous les organismes ne
réagissent pas de la même façon aux
médicaments aux midasolables et aux
antalgiques et les équipes comme la
disjonetti au bout d'un certain temps
prennent des décisions d'adaptation de
la sédation donc on partage cette
analyse et je crois qu'il faut pas se
cacher et se le dire y compris dans ce
rapport d'évaluation
voilà ce que je pouvais dire en
introduction de notre rapport qu'on a
travaillé ensemble je dirais dans un
esprit tout à fait
collaboratif et de chercher finalement
la les meilleures formulations je sais
qu'il y a des mots qui peuvent irriter
les uns et les autres parce que aussi on
a peut-être pas été parfait dans notre
rédaction
mais la perfection n'existe pas ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est l'intention
globale de nos recommandations
alors juste en conclusion effectivement
remercier les administrateurs ce qui a
déjà été fait le président est mon
collègue Cora porteur j'ai quand même je
tenais à le dire on nous parle beaucoup
de enfin souvent de co-construction il
serait bien que les députés travaillent
ensemble c'est faisable et réalisable
on sait faire et
non c'était pas pour toi
les travaux de la mission donc montrent
que dans le cadre juridique institué par
la loi clef génétique ça répond à une
grande partie de la majorité des
situations de fin de vie dans la plupart
des cas dans les soins palliatifs les
malades ne demandent plus à mourir
lorsqu'ils sont pris en charge
accompagnés de manière adéquate pour
autant il conviendra rappeler que le cas
de législatif actuel n'apporte pas de
réponse à toutes les situations de fin
de vie en particulier lorsque le
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à court
terme comme la souligner le Comité
consultatif national d'éthique dans son
avis 139 en septembre 2022
dans le contexte du débat public actuel
la question de la dactive va mourir a
souvent été longuement et spontanément
évoqué par les personnes auditionnées
alors qu'elle n'était pas l'objet de la
mission d'évaluation n'apparaît donc pas
dans le rapport bien que minoritaire ces
situations méritent sans doute toute
notre attention et il sera important que
le législateur à la suite de la
convention citoyenne débattent et se
positionne prochainement sur cette
question merci
bien merci je remercie les rapporteurs
ainsi que le président et nous allons
passer à présent aux orateurs de groupe
et nous commençons tout de suite avec
Charlotte Parmentier Lecoq pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente je voulais à mon tour saluer
la qualité du travail de nos trois
rapporteurs et aussi le climat
constructif dans lequel vous avez mené
ces travaux
la question de la fin de vie et des
conditions d'une fin de vie digne
constitue une préoccupation majeure et
actuelle de notre société chacun des
députés ici présents et régulièrement
interpellé par nos concitoyens et
souvent à la suite d'une douloureuse
expérience pour l'un de ses proches
la question de la fin de vie a fait
l'objet de nombreux travaux
parlementaires et je salue au passage
l'engagement de notre ancien collègue
jean-Louis Touraine
elle est aussi l'objet d'une convention
citoyenne promise par le Président de la
République et qui doit rendre
prochainement ses travaux en parallèle
vous avez donc conduit cet évaluation de
la dernière loi votée au parlement la
loi dite classe Leonetti cette loi qui
crée en particulier l'accès à une
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès
que pouvez-vous nous dire ça rapporteur
de ce nouveau droit créé par la loi
est-il d'abord connu des patients et de
leurs proches
dans quelles circonstances particulières
est-il utilisé est-il requis et par quel
type de patient et j'étais interpellé
justement par l'exemple qui a été évoqué
par notre collègue Didier Martin est-ce
que vous pouvez
développer un peu justement le la
typologie de passion qui peuvent
recourir j'allais dire aussi peut-être
dans de bonnes conditions à ce droit et
à contrario dans quelles circonstances
vous avez pu constater à travers vos
travaux que ce droit n'était pas
accessible ou n'était pas requis ou
peut-être pas suffisamment adapté par
rapport à l'objectif d'une sédation
profonde et continue et sereine aussi
attendu par par les patients en fin de
vie merci merci bien la parole est à
Madame
Sandrine de gorc sucre pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur de la
grande majorité des 31 auditions
réalisées par la mission de dont j'étais
membre les ressorts que la loi laisse
Leonetti est utile bien
qu'insuffisamment connu et appliqué ces
dispositions restent largement méconnues
des patients mais aussi des soignants
pourquoi dès lors conclure votre rapport
en disant qu'il est crucial que le
législateur débatte et se positionne
prochainement sur la question de l'aide
active à mourir alors que l'aveux même
du rapport il est indispensable de
continuer à développer massivement les
soins palliatifs afin que les droits des
malades prévus par la loi soient
pleinement garantie partout en France
mais vous recommandations ne tendent pas
vers leur développement massive donc
comme nous l'ont confirmé les auditions
21 départements français sont encore
dépourvus d'unité de soins palliatifs
avant d'envisager une quelconque
évolution ne faut-il pas d'abord
appliquer correctement la loi la vraie
question se pose la volonté de la part
du gouvernement est-elle développée
est-elle de les développer est-elle là
pardon on peut en effet sainte Roger
quand on voit les 10,1 millions par an à
louer par le cinquième plan de
développement des soins et palliatifs
alors que la safap estime qu'il faudrait
800 millions d'euros par an bien sûr
votre rapport rénoce quelques
recommandations pour garantir l'accès
aux soins palliatifs mais il n'en fait
pas une priorité ce qui ce que je
regrette plusieurs témoignages
recueillis lors des auditions relèvent
que les deux mains de fin de vie active
sont moindres dès lors que l'on anticipe
la question de la prise en charge en
soins palliatifs d'où l'important c'est
essentielle de remédier à ces grandes
disparités d'offres sur notre territoire
même les participations à la Convention
citoyenne qui rendra ses conclusions
dimanche reprochent l’omission de
discussion sur les soins palliatifs
s'adressant au comité de gouvernance de
cette convention ils sont un certain
nombre à estimer que les débats et les
délibérations semblent orientées vers un
changement de la loi à tout prix malgré
les travaux sur l'amélioration de la loi
actuelle et leur intérêt pour les soins
palliatifs merci merci bien madame Elisa
Martin pour la France insoumise nupesse
merci madame la Présidente j'ai toujours
des soucis avec ces microbes mais
évidemment c'est absolument mineur au vu
des de ce dont nous sommes en train de
discuter d'abord
même si
bien sûr on peut on peut toujours on
peut toujours aller plus loin mais moi
je tiens à vous remercier
très précisément du travail que vous
avez fourni et des conclusions que vous
avez rendues parce qu'on est sur un
sujet qui est complexe
qui relève de questions
philosophiques éthique qui relève aussi
du choix de chacun qui en ces matières
nés de toute façon pas discutable
et vous avez raison d'insister sur la
notion de droit
ces décisions qui ne sont pas
discutables relèvent du droit du droit
de chacun du droit de chacun
à choisir sa mort même si moi je
j'hésite tout de même sur sur cette
expression bon dans la mesure où je ne
suis pas certaine qu'on choisit sa mort
en tant que telle en revanche
aujourd'hui dans un pays comme le nôtre
appuyé de surcroît sur ce que vous avez
réussi à dégager comme comme consensus
c'est le chemin qui relève du choix et
ce chemin là évidemment il doit être
balisé et il doit être
garanti garantie pour pour chacun donc
une traduction juridique d'enjeux
philosophique éthique et qui relève
encore une fois du choix du choix de
chacun et donc de d'aspect qui sont
particulièrement intimes et il y a
toujours une complexité quand la loi
s'invite dans dans ses choix là
évidemment ce qui nous frappe et qui
devra incontestablement
faire l'objet non seulement de réflexion
mais au-delà de ça d'engagement
d'engagement financier d'engagement de
conviction d'engagement
d'un travail auprès des auprès des des
soignants dont évidemment c'est dit à
plusieurs reprises ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas la fileuse leur philosophie cette
accompagnement bref qui est la question
des moyens
il faudra de toute façon d'une façon ou
d'une autre travailler ce sujet sinon du
coup le droit et le chemin n'est pas
respecté
l'autre chose que je veux que je veux
dire vous avez dépassé votre pardon je
croyais qu'il me restait 40 secondes bon
alors écoutez
oui oui je j'ai bien vu je me disais
tiens ici ça fonctionne du nom ça
fonctionne très bien une autre manière
madame je ne me permettrai évidemment
pas de dire quoi que ce soit qui
relèverait de lors d'une critique non
simplement ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'à la question de la plasticité et de
l'adaptation je vous prie de m'excuser
très bien Madame la Députée vous êtes
excusé monsieur Thibault Bazin pour les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues les
travaux très instructifs de notre
mission d'évaluation de la loi du 2
février 2016 créé un nouveau droit en
faveur des malades et des personnes en
fin de vie dites clayesonetti se conclut
il nous appartient désormais des
éclairer nos compatriotes sur l'état de
l'application concrète de cette loi en
étant des relais fidèles des témoignages
reçus quelle évaluation en faisons-nous
d'abord que notre pays souffre d'un
maillage très lacunaire trop lacunaire
en service de soins palliatifs et que
les carences constatées durent depuis
des décennies sans qu'une action
publique adéquate ne soit menée en
réponse ensuite qu'il existe toujours
dans certains établissements des
difficultés d'accès aux soins palliatifs
et que le droit des Français en
bénéficier chez eux demeurent largement
théoriques enfin qu'une trop faible
appropriation des dispositions de cette
loi perdure et ce chez les soignants
comme chez les patients en somme il a
paru que le déploiement de la loi kless
Leonetti restait largement affaire mais
ce n'est pas une fatalité des solutions
concrètes existent comme le prouve
recommandations de nos rapporteurs
auxquels je voudrais m'associer il me
semble également important de rappeler
qu'au cours de ces auditions la
philosophie les principes et l'équilibre
éthique de cette loi ont été saluées le
docteur Fourcade en a parlé comme je
cite d'un trésor national qui est à la
fois sécurisant pour les soignants et
qui nous permet de dire aux patients on
va vous accompagner je conclurai donc en
nous appelant collectivement à garder le
cap comme l'a écrit très justement
récemment notre collègue Pierre
dareville cette loi est un message
d'espoir de toute la société dont les
soignants sont les porteurs nous
n'aborderons pas nous ne vous
abandonnons pas nous comptons les uns
sur les autres et les uns pour les
autres ensemble mes chers collègues
cette mission d'évaluation nous a appris
que beaucoup restent à faire pour
concrétiser ce message d'espoir dans la
vie de nos compatriotes ni eux ne sont
pas préservons notre idéal de fraternité
ne cédons pas à la culture de la mort
qui serait une pente dangereuse une
pente Funès pour nous concitoyens en
situation de vulnérabilité en situation
de fragilité alors déployant vraiment
une culture palliative qui accompagne
partout et pour tous ce serait à
l'honneur de la France de porter une
telle ambition avec une profonde
reconnaissance pour nos soignants qui
prennent en charge les malades et les
accompagne de manière adéquate merci
bien elle la parole est à Philippe
Vigier pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président cher
Olivier falornis salut naturellement les
deux corps rapporteurs Caroline Fiat et
Didier Martin
il est des moments où le Parlement
sonore
et il se nomme par la qualité du travail
que vous avez fait
je pense que ces propos prennent une
résonance particulière
loin
d'autres moments qu'on a pu vivre
récemment et ce qui montre bien que
lorsqu'il s'agit de sujets aussi graves
que de la vie qui concerne chacun
d'entre nous
de l'ultime rendez-vous que nous aurons
tous on doit me semble-t-il faire preuve
d'une intelligence collective d'un
respect mutuel et là où centre choc la
philosophie
naturellement l'engagement de chacun et
je voudrais souligner donc ce travail
s'est inscrit dans le prolongement de ce
qui a toujours été fait sur ces
questions tellement difficiles et
tellement douloureuses
après il a conscience citoyenne qui est
là qui est un pour ceux qui imaginaient
que les conventions citoyennes ne
servaient à rien je crois qu'au moins
ils auront l'exemple qu'elle sert à
quelque chose
et que la rencontre de l'intelligence de
la convention citoyenne et des travaux
que vous avez fait doit être à mes yeux
l'élément fondateur pour justement aller
plus loin sur les applications telles
qu'elles ont été relevées par Didier
Martin et Caroline Fiat encore
insuffisante à ce jour mais je voudrais
juste dire en conclusion que ce travaux
nous engage pour la suite
on ne peut pas déplorer d'un côté le
fait qu'il y ait des maillages en soins
palliatifs qui ne soit pas là et ensuite
laisser de côté lorsqu'on aura des
textes budgétaires à la rentrée on ne
peut pas considérer que la situation
profonde et continue et mal pratiqué
parce que mal connu et après il a essayé
de côté on ne peut pas laisser me
semble-t-il aussi les directives
anticipées le tiers de confiance ne pas
être bien informé alors que on a tous
les moyens pour faire alors soyons
audacieux soyons dans la droite qui ne
ce que vous avez fait merci pour celles
et ceux qui nous regardent merci bien la
parole est à Marie-Noëlle baptistel pour
le groupe socialiste et apparenté dupes
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
voudrais évidemment à mon tour remercier
président et rapporteur pour l'excellent
travail qu'ils ont fourni 7 ans après la
loi Claes il était évidemment
extrêmement important de pouvoir
l'évaluer et de poser les bases
éventuellement d'un futur travail et ce
que vous
énoncez dans votre rapport montre bien
qu'il doit y avoir une poursuite à ce
travail tant sur l'accès aux soins
palliatifs
et on peut évidemment s'alarmer de vos
conclusions qui confirment d'ailleurs ce
que nous avons constaté il y a deux ans
lors des débats sur la PPL fa Learny une
œuvre de soins palliatifs largement
insuffisante avec 21 départements qui ne
disposent pas d'une unité de soins
palliatifs de tiers des malades
nécessitant des soins palliatifs qui n'y
ont pas accès évidemment la pénurie de
soignants n'arrange pas la situation et
la question des soins palliatifs à
domicile est également un sujet
extrêmement
important notamment dans tout les
milieux ou les centres hospitaliers ne
sont pas du tout en proximité donc je
voudrais évidemment vous remercier pour
les bonnes recommandations pour pallier
à cela autant sur la garantie de l'accès
aux soins palliatifs mais aussi
d'améliorer les connaissances sur la fin
de vie et de mieux faire connaître les
directives anticipées et les personnes à
la personne de confiance et surtout
rendre effectif le droit à la sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès
puisqu'elle est pratiquée d'à peu près
1%
par contre je voudrais exprimer
peut-être ma crainte que ces conclusions
n'aillent que dans le sens d'une
consolidation de l'existant plutôt
qu'une évolution
sur verled active à mourir et je
voudrais vous poser à tous les trois une
question si après tous ces mois
d'audition et l'écoute de plus de 90
acteurs vous êtes toujours convaincus
qu'il est nécessaire d'aller plus loin
en inscrivant dans la loi comme nous
l'avions porté collectivement il y a
deux ans le fait de garantir un chèque
être humain le droit à une fin de vie
libre et choisit grâce notamment à
l'accès aux soins palliatifs et à
l'assistance médicale active à mourir je
vous remercie très bien merci la parole
est à Monsieur Frédéric valtoux pour
horizon et apparentés
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
ajouter ma voix à celle qui vient de
s'exprimer pour remercier le président
Olivier Falorni mais aussi les corateurs
Caroline Fiat et Didier Martin pour le
travail très très fin très sensible
qu'ils ont mené mais en même temps très
fouillé et documenté à travers toutes
les auditions bien sûr mais à travers
les conclusions qui ont été tirées c'est
une vraie avancée dans la mise en œuvre
et dans l'appréciation d'une loi qui
avait marqué une rupture en son temps ou
plutôt qui avait offert un cadre qui
était une véritable avancée aussi bien
bien sûr pour les patients mais aussi
pour les soignants qui parfois avaient
l'impression d'évoluer en zone grise
pour pour dire rapidement
vous montrer effectivement
à la fois les limites et peut-être les
les avancées nécessaires pour développer
encore la loi kless et ce qu'il offre
comme nouveau cadre les disparités
territoriales dans la répartition des
unités de soins palliatifs bien sûr et
vous appelez à la redéfinition des
règles de financement où on voit bien
aussi l'importance qu'il y a et vous
l'avez évoqué à l'instant d'adapter les
formations effectivement vous soulignez
le fait que vous n'avez pas eu le temps
et c'est peut-être un travail qu'il
faudra un jour faire à bien apprécier
l'évaluation de l'adéquation entre les
besoins et l'offre on voit que c'est
sans doute un travail qui aurait mérité
un temps plus complet et sans doute des
moyens plus importants mais mais sans
doute ça viendra
moi je pense à titre personnel que dans
les difficultés qui ont été que vous
évoquez il y a sans doute aussi une mise
en oeuvre de cette loi classique
léonétique a parfois pu être gêné par
une confusion éthique entre la fois le
cadre que posait cette loi mais aussi
les débats sur le tanasile d'active à
mourir qui peut-être parfois dans dans
l'esprit à la fois de certains patients
mais aussi chez les soignants ont pu
parfois poser à sa tombe de questions
qui n'ont sans doute pas aidé à diffuser
mieux cette
la connaissance de cette de ce cadre
juridique ça serait donc ma question au
terme de cette évaluation et des
entretiens poussés vous avez eu avec
toutes les personnes rencontrées quel
serait pour vous les moyens de mieux
faire connaître à la fois
aux patients mais aussi aux équipes
soignantes
l'apport les apports de cette loi classe
lonetti comment mieux arriver à
surmonter cette handicap
fondamental que vous soulignez qui est
la bonne appropriation et la bonne
connaissance de ces dispositifs par les
uns les autres merci beaucoup merci bien
la parole est à Sébastien Petavy pour le
groupe écologiste nupes
merci madame la Présidente alors nous
remercions le travail fourni dans ce
rapport alors de ce rapport nous faisons
un constat celui que l'article 1 de la
loi classelonoïti qui pose le droit à
une fin de vie digne n'a pas toujours
réalisé sa promesse si l'accès à l'aide
active à mourir est toujours pas une
réalité la compagnement de tous les
patients patients en proie à des
souffrances insupportables ne l'est pas
non plus le rapport le reconnaît de
lui-même les deux tiers des malades
nécessitant des soins palliatifs n'y ont
toujours pas accès car le secteur du
soin palliatifs n'échappe pas au
contexte de pénurie chronique de
personnels soignants avoir le droit à
une fin de vie digne passe d'abord par
permettre à chacun et à chacune de ne
pas passer les derniers moments de sa
vie dans la souffrance et à ce sujet
l'État a failli à sa promesse et la
tarification à l'activité ne fait que
renforcer cet abandon car là où la
préservation de la dignité du patient
devrait être au cœur des soins le
système de tarification à l'activité
contribuer à une déshumanisation des
patients allant parfois jusqu'à
l'obstination des raisonnables le
rapport constate que le cadre juridique
de la loi classe loanetti répond à une
majorité des situations de fin de vie
mais il reconnaît aussi un défaut de
réponse aux besoins de certains patients
ainsi les soins palliatifs et l'aide
médicale à mourir n'ont pas à s'opposer
nous devons prendre conscience de la
diversité des façons d'envisager la mort
et le chemin vers celle-ci en ce sens le
groupe écologiste rappelle que nous ne
sions pas que pour certains mais pour
l'ensemble des concitoyens il est
inhumain de laisser une partie des
patients dont un état de souffrance
continue ainsi respecter la dignité de
tous c'est également respecter la
liberté de chacun de partir comme il le
souhaite alors que l'accès aux soins
palliatifs est inégalement réparti sur
le territoire et que certains pourront
déjà accéder à l'aide active à mourir à
l'étranger ce que nous retenons de ce
rapport c'est qu'aux inégalités de vie
s'ajoutent finalement celle face à la
mort ainsi nous devons sortir du déni
face à l'impossibilité de soigner
certaines douleurs à supporter
insurmontable et de situations complexes
car laisser un patient dans une lente
agonie alors qu'il soit partir Nanni
courageux ni prof de bonté c'est un
abandon plus récent auquel nous devons
remédier sans attente merci
bien Monsieur Pierre d'arréville pour la
Gauche démocrate et républicaine nupes
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
d'abord remercier nos trois collègues
pour la qualité de ce rapport utile à
nourrir le débat et l'action publique
sur les enjeux des soins palliatifs on
parle trop souvent sans connaître cette
grande loi ni c'est possible ni son
application
ni les défauts de son application j'ai
un regret car il ne faudrait pas que que
cela fasse passer à la trappe le contenu
éclairant de votre rapport que vous
concluiez votre conclusion sur l'aide
active à mourir sans que les travaux y
conduisent mais il est clair que ces
constats peuvent alimenter le débat
actuel malgré le manque de données ce
rapport montre l'insuffisance cliente
des moyens à louer aux soins palliatifs
et les effets pervers de la tarification
à l'activité qui plus est pour une prise
en charge qui requiert avant tout de
l'humain bien au-delà des gestes
codifiés et protocolisés c'est là un
défaut majeur dans le risque avait été
pointé dès la première loi Léonetti
cette réalité débouche sur des
inégalités d'accès en l'occurrence vous
avez pointé des inégalités territoriales
indéfendables or pour soigner il y a une
obligation de moyens mais face à la fin
de vie c'est pour l'État une obligation
absolue quand une personne humaine se
trouve face à la mort face à l'épreuve
ultime d'une vie la communauté humaine
n'a pas le droit de ne pas être au
rendez-vous cette exigence de moyens est
fondamentalement une exigence éthique
sans quoi on nourrit l'angoisse
individuel et collectif face à la mort
vous pointez la nécessité de faire
progresser et partager la culture
palliative pour qu'elle puisse
intervenir au bon moment vous soulevez
un certain nombre de questions autour de
la sédation profonde et continue à
propos de laquelle il faut à mon sens
réfuter les procès relativistes en
hypocrisie car il est indispensable que
les gestes étant sens que nous devons
cultiver vous pointez le succès relatif
des directives anticipées dispositif
sans doute méconnus mais qui doit rester
une possibilité que l'on actionne ou pas
c'est constats appellent des actes
concrets de la puissance publique je
vous remercie vivement de votre travail
merci bien Monsieur Laurent liberté
indépendante outre-mer et territoire je
ne savais pas s'il fallait prononcer le
S ou pas je suis le député pour la
prochaine fois on a la présidente merci
durant plusieurs semaines la mission
d'évaluation a entendu une grande
diversité d'acteurs d'intervenants de
professionnels de citoyens sensibles à
la question de la fin de vie et ce dans
le cadre de la loi cléonetti ma première
observation ce qui frappe à l'analyse de
ces entretiens de ce rapport et la
relation difficile de notre société à la
mort que ce soit par les professionnels
ou autre une mort souvent envisagée sous
l'angle de l'échec thérapeutique et par
conséquent des soins pallatifs objets de
cette loi comme une forme de gestion
exceptionnelle de ce qui constitue
encore une forme de tabou dans notre
société 7 ans après la mise en oeuvre de
la loi la mission a pu révéler plusieurs
points marquants
d'abord et c'est probablement le plus
important la cause des autres
difficultés les dispositifs de la loi
sont largement méconnues des patients
mais aussi des soignants alors que la
loi instaure une valeur contraignante ou
directive anticipées mais aussi précises
et réaffirme le rôle de la personne de
confiance deux avancées pourtant
structurantes essentielles ces
dispositifs restent remarquablement peu
mobilisés autre difficulté l'absence de
donner sur la pratique des différents
types de sédation la sédation profonde
et continue jusqu'au décès pratiquée de
manière très exceptionnelle cette
avancée majeure dans la pratique des
soins palliatifs est également un droit
inconnu de la plupart des malades et un
acte médical pratiqué de manière très
inégale l'accès aux soins palliatifs les
différents outils de la loi clé
cinétique s'avère donc globalement
insatisfaisant à la ville comme un
établissement ces faiblesses sont
multifactorielles liés à la pénurie de
soignants un modèle de financement
défavorable et surtout de façon plus
générale une très faible diffusion de la
culture palliative en France
formation de tous les professionnels de
santé informations des Français moyen
matériel et humains sont autant
d'objectifs indispensables à
l'application pleine et entière de la
loi ce rapport le démontre cette loi
pleinement appliquée répondrait à ses
objectifs
enfin au-delà de ce travail certaines
situations de fin de vie en dehors du
cadre de cette loi en naturellement et
régulièrement été abordé la question de
l'aide actif à mourir devra donc
inévitablement faire l'objet d'un
travail spécifique ce rapport
retranscrit tout cela clairement et je
veux remercier l'ensemble des membres de
la mission merci merci
le député alors nous avons quelques
questions je les fais passer vous êtes
d'accord vous voulez répondre monsieur
le Président mais Monsieur Madame la
rapporte vous voulez vous préférez
répondre donc je passe la parole au
rapporteur et ensuite on passera aux
questions
merci madame la Présidente
j'ai relevé quelques questions
concernant la typologie des patients qui
peuvent accéder aux soins palliatifs ça
va du nourrisson
au centenaire
il y a pas d'âge pour mourir on peut
mourir à tout âge et c'est ça qui est
bien compliqué pour les soignants
la loi est-elle connue et la non c'est
ce qu'on explique que dans le rapport
que ce soit par les soignants que par
les usagers donc c'est vraiment une
grande mission que l'on pourrait avoir
le législateur de tout mettre en place
pour que tout le monde puisse connaître
cette loi en sachant là c'est mon avis
je précise que
dans la société française parler de la
mort est très tabou et donc ça n'aide
pas à faire connaître ce genre de
pratique
pour les remarques concernant la fin du
rapport il me semble il aurait été très
malhonnête alors que toutes nos
auditions sont parties sur la dative à
mourir de ne pas en parler dans la
conclusion on en a pas fait une
recommandation ni une préconisation
parce que on ne le souhaitait pas
c'était pas le but de notre rapport mais
quand on voit que il n'y a pas eu une
seule audition sans que le sujet Vienne
sur le tapis on ne pouvait pas ne pas
conclure ainsi j'ose espérer que ce ne
sera pas la seule chose qui sera retenue
de notre magnifique rapport avec toute
l'objectivité que vous me connaissez
concernant
la dactive à mourir et nos
positionnements
je donnerai pas mon positionnement
aujourd'hui parce que ça ne m'a trop
tenu à coeur que notre rapport ne soit
pas là dessus
après vous connaissez
globalement je pense les avis mais c'est
vraiment pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui et
on a bien terminé en que les
législateurs devraient s'emparer du
sujet on n'a pas dit on n'a pas donné de
consignes de vote sur le sujet
concernant les moyens de faire connaître
la loi classe leetti
la communication en parler toutes et
tous déjà chacun autour de soi je n'ose
pas vous faire la fronde de vous de
faire lever la main et de vous demander
qui a rempli ces directives anticipées
dans cette salle mais si déjà le
législateur ne le fait pas vous imaginez
bien que chez des Français c'est pas
mieux
non non on écoute madame la rapporteur
mes chers collègues mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que alors qui connaît les
directives anticipées et exactement la
définition de la personne de confiance
on pourrait être très étonné et en fait
je terminerai les réponses par ce que je
dis depuis très longtemps il ne faut pas
opposer les soins palliatifs avec
une éventuelle législation sur l'aide
active à mourir les deux ont
un tracé
différents et je vais citer Didier
Martin il m'en voudra pas mais j'ai
trouvé ça tellement beau et simple
les soins palliatifs
c'est une loi pour les gens qui vont
mourir et l'aide active à mourir c'est
pour les gens qui veulent mourir et les
mots leur importance mais je précise que
c'est pas ça vient pas de moi mais je
trouvais ça bien donc je vais le pique
monsieur le rapporteur
merci
pour Madame Parmentier madame la député
vous oui la loi sur en particulier sur
la sédation et mal connue mais
globalement la loi est mal connue mal
connu du public et aussi parfois mal
connue des soignants je parle pas des
soignants qui travaillent des services
de réanimation je parle pas de ceux qui
sont en gériatrie ni en unités bien sûr
mais tous les autres soignants je dois
dire que bien que leur formation
incluent des modules sur les soins
palliatifs et c'est vrai pour les
aides-soignants c'est vrai pour les
infirmières c'est vrai pour les médecins
il y a besoin de davantage faire
d'informations et d'informations des
personnels soignants pour que toutes ces
dispositions tous ces droits toutes ces
obligations aussi l'obligation de
soulager sur la douleur sur tous les
types de douleurs tout ça soit bien
en possession de tous les soignants
parce que effectivement pour certains il
y aura des décisions à prendre en
particulier dans le cadre de la
discussion collégiale
vous me demandez si elle est mal
pratiquée non je peux je n'ai rien nous
n'avons rien pour dire que cette
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès mal appliqué non nous n'avons pas
recueilli de renseignements là-dessus
mais là encore là encore le grand bémol
c'est que
le résultat des discussions collégiales
et des décisions collégiales ne figure
que dans les dossiers médicaux auxquels
nous n'avons pas accès donc je dois être
prudent à vous répondre pour Madame
degor such et d'autres
qui ont parlé de moyens financiers
certes des moyens financiers et nous le
verrons peut-être dans les exercices
budgétaires à venir
ce qui est important aussi de comprendre
c'est que pour les soins palliatifs ce
sont les moyens humains qui comptent
essentiellement parce que c'est une
médecine soit palliatifs c'est une
médecine qui est une médecine au chevet
des patients qui consiste à passer du
temps auprès des patients pour être à
leur écoute pour recueillir leur volonté
pour savoir quelle est leur bien-être
quel est leur confort et proposer des
solutions adaptées à chaque individu il
n'y a pas de
protocoles applicables à chacun donc
cette médecine moins technique moins
performante au sens des progrès
techniques on attribue à la médecine
contemporaine
de l'accompagnement et du service cette
médecine elle s'oppose
au temps rapide autant et aussi à la
tarification à l'acte telle que la T2A
l'a mis en place c'est pour ça que nous
avons une proposition d'adapter cette
T2A et de tracer les moyens financiers
décider au niveau national pour les
soins palliatifs tracés dans tous les
budgets hospitaliers l'affectation de
ces moyens financiers effectivement aux
unités ne soient palliatives
et donc cette réponse sur le temps c'est
aussi pour madame Martin qui qui
m'interrogeait sur ce plan
pour Monsieur Bazin
ma collègue Caroline m'ayant cité je ne
peux que répéter cette loi classique
elle était conçue elle était rédigée
pour ceux qui vont mourir dans les jours
à venir très précisément dans ce cadre
là avec bien sûr
une souffrance qu'on ne peut pas apaiser
avec bien sûr un pronostic vital et une
maladie incurable la question de l'aide
active à mourir se posera pour ceux qui
veulent mourir c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont
un pronostic qui est au-delà de ce
quelques jours et donc on ne peut pas je
tiens à préserver ce trésor national qui
est la loi clesson éthique certains nous
envies y compris ce qu'on met en place
l'euthanasie et je tiens aussi à
souligner l'important cette culture
palliative qui doit
intervenir en
lors de la prise en charge des maladies
je m'explique c'est pas quand on a fini
de
traiter avec les chimiothérapies des
radiothérapies pour prendre l'exemple du
cancer et que on est au bout de
traitement qu'on passe le relais qu'on
soit palliatifs il faut effectivement
qu'il y a non je sais vous n'avez pas
dit le contraire je vous explique que
cette enchaînement des soins palliatifs
ils doivent venir bien en amont pour
cette accès aux champs palliatifs je
partage avec tous ceux qui l'ont dit le
déficit les lacunes de l'offre de soins
palliatifs dans tous les territoires
c'est dans l'article 1 de la loi
klessonetti des premières lignes sur
l'ensemble du territoire sur l'ensemble
du territoire donc nous devons nous
attacher à ce que tout le territoire
soit couvert
sur l'intervention de monsieur valthou
qui parle des très justement
d'évaluation qui était notre travail
lorsque la loi initiale ne prévoit pas
elle-même très précisément des
indicateurs que seront les valuation a
postériori il est très difficile de le
faire donc ça je crois que c'est quelque
chose que nous devons tous intégrer si
on veut effectivement en termes
d'adéquation en termes de qualité de
rapport offre demande être en capacité
d'évaluer ce que nous avons décidé par
la loi et ce qui était mis en oeuvre il
nous faut intégrer ces éducateurs ces
indicateurs pardon soit dans la loi soit
dans des décrets à venir mais nous
devons absolument le préciser pour que
effectivement on puisse quand on fait ce
travail là 7 ans comme l'a dit le
président phalornit 7 ans après que la
loi soit votée il n'y avait pas eu de
rapport d'évaluation alors que l'article
14 de la loi prévoyait un rapport annuel
alors nous avons été raisonnables nous
avons dit il faut passer de un an tous
les deux ans ça sera suffisant mais il
faut que ce soit fait et il faut que on
décide clairement quels seront les
indicateurs les gars qui s'est penchées
sur la loi classique avait fait des
recommandations dans ce sens on peut
aussi n'est pas interdit de les écouter
pour prévoir cette évaluation parce que
ça fait partie aussi des politiques de
santé donc des politiques publiques
voilà ce que je pouvais dire globalement
même si je réponds pas particulièrement
Monsieur Petavy et Monsieur dareville
oui des questions financières ça compte
oui l'égalité territoriale s'accompte et
l'accompagnement éthique face à la mort
[Musique]
on n'est pas là pour parler de la mort
parce que c'est très difficile et c'est
métaphysique en revanche que ce soit en
soins palliatifs ou dans notre dans nos
travaux de législateur il faut parler de
la vie et je pense que l'entrée en soit
palliatif est une nouvelle étape de la
vie certes c'est la dernière et ça doit
être abordé comme une nouvelle étape de
la vie merci bien monsieur le président
oui
quelques mots sur peut-être le point
central de vos interrogations
sur l'acétation profonde et continue
maintenant jusqu'au décès
c'est logique ce cœur de nos
interrogations puisque c'est la grande
nouveauté de ce texte
en fait la loi Leonetti de 2005 avait
déjà intégré les directives anticipées
la personne de confiance avait affirmé
le refus de l'obstination des
raisonnables et l'accès aux soins
palliatifs pour tous la grande nouveauté
c'était d'apporter ce qui devait être
une solution la sédation profonde et
continue maintenant jusqu'au décès qui
pouvait être pratiqué parfois en
complément de des sédation
proportionnelle c'est cette question qui
est au cœur de tout parce que c'est
d'ailleurs un des titres de notre
rapport c'est une procédure qui
interroge ce qui nous interroge nous
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
ne pouvons-nous pas
avoir déjà accès aux chiffres
nous sommes incapables de vous dire
aujourd'hui combien de sédations
profondes et continue jusqu'au décès
sont pratiqués dans ce pays nous n'en
sommes pas capables parce que cet acte
n'est pas codifié
donc nous sommes sur du déclaratif mais
le déclaratif il va dans le même sens
quel qu'en soit les motivations on
pratique très très peu la sédation
profonde et continue aujourd'hui voilà
ensuite
il y a deux raisons qui nous ont été
données pour cette non pratique de la
sédation profonde et continue et quelque
part ça ouvre les deux analyses que l'on
peut avoir de la loi
soit d'un côté très hors national comme
le dit le docteur claire Fourcade d'un
autre côté le professeur Martin Lombard
qui nous dit cette loi est inappliquée
parce qu'elle est inapplicable vous
voyez il y a des analyses différentes
si cette sédation profonde et continue
n'est pas appliquée pour un certain
nombre notamment de soignants c'est
qu'elle n'est pas forcément
utile et que les sédations
proportionnées suffisent dans la
majorité des cas bon je rappelle quand
même que Jean Leonetti a commencé son
propos en disant que alors que la
souffrance devrait être interdite dans
ce pays 12% des malades hurlent de
douleur dans les hôpitaux parisiens je
cite bon je cite 12% des malades hurle
de douleur dans les hôpitaux parisiens
aujourd'hui
voilà donc je ne fais que citer je sais
pas d'où il tient ces chiffres mais nous
l'avons d'ailleurs cité dans le rapport
donc d'un côté on nous dit la sédation
profondé continue n'est pas utile d'un
autre côté on nous dit la sédation
profonde et continue n'est pas utilisée
parce qu'elle pose un certain nombre de
problèmes
elle prose elle prône elle pose le
problème de l'intentionnalité
c'est à dire cette limite
ténue entre l'aide d'activent mourir et
la sédation profondé continue il y a une
différence d'intention incontestable
mais chez certains soignants il y a
cette difficulté parce que une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès
comme son nom l'indique c'est qu'elle a
vocation à être irréversible
irréversible
c'est à dire que il ne doit pas y avoir
de réveil et une des inquiétudes des
soignants c'est que parfois il y en a
la deuxième difficulté la sédation
profonde et continue c'est qu'elle est
quasi impossible à pratiquer aujourd'hui
à domicile alors que c'est un droit
inscrit dans la loi castleonetti il n'y
a c'est très difficile de faire de la
sédation profonde et continue à domicile
très difficile pour plein de raisons je
peux pas développer et puis il y a la
question de la maîtrise du temps qui
inquiète beaucoup les soignants parce
que quand vous plongez quelqu'un dans la
sédation profondé continue
vous ne savez pas combien de temps ça va
durer
vous ne savez pas et on a eu un
témoignage Didier en parler d'un d'un
réanimateur en néonat qui avait plongé
un nourrisson
en sédation profonde et continue je vais
pas rentrer dans les détails mais ça a
duré plus longtemps qu'il ne l'espérait
et il y a aussi la limitation de l'accès
à la sédation profonde et continue la
loi impose qu'elle ne soit pratiquée que
si pronostiqué engagé à court terme
c'est à dire sur quelques heures ou
quelques jours voilà donc ça limite
forcément le recours à cette outil
le Conseil d'État qui n'est pas
habituellement
j'allais dire
coutumier de porter des jugements
éthiques parler de ce malade qui n'en
finit pas de mourir
donc c'est
un point que Conseil d'État puisque il y
a eu deux évaluations sur cette loi
aucune parlementaire comme on a dit il y
a eu deux évaluations en 2018 de façon
trop précoce une de ligace qui prenait
la codification de la sédation profonde
et continue on attend toujours 5 ans
après et le Conseil d'État qui disait
attention à ces situations le malade
n'en finit pas de mourir donc vous voyez
que sur la sédation profonde et continue
nous nous interrogeons je m'interroge
sur le non recours à ce dispositif
qui peut être interprété de deux façons
nous ne tranchons pas mais
comme disait l'autre j'ai mon avis et je
le partage
merci bien monsieur le Président donc
nous allons poursuivre avec les
questions qui nous restent donc à poser
madame Fanta Beretti vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues je vous remercie pour vos
présentations et vos premières réponses
un travail réalisé en plus dans le
dépassement c'est vraiment très
appréciable ce rapport que nous
examinons arrive à un moment où le débat
sur la fin de vie ne font que commencer
et où nous sommes déjà interpellés par
un certain nombre de Français à ce sujet
par ailleurs nous avons la proposition
de loi du Bien Vieillir qui arrivera
dans quelques jours en commission votre
rabat votre rapport à l'ordre entre
autres la question de mieux faire
connaître les directives anticipées et
la personne de confiance en effet depuis
la loi du 4 mars 2002
toute personne peut désigner une
personne de confiance qui sera consultée
en cas d'impossibilité d'exprimer sa
volonté de recevoir l'information
nécessaire et les pouvoirs publics ont
donc tenté de démocratiser si je puis
dire cette désignation en impliquant
davantage le médecin traitant qui est en
pratique la pratique l'interlocuteur
médical le plus proche du patient la loi
du 2 février 2016 évoque dans le cadre
du suivi de son patient le médecin
traitant s'assure que celui-ci est
informé de la possibilité de désigner
une personne de confiance et le cas
échéant l'invite à procéder à une telle
désignation ma question est donc la
suivante comment selon vous peut-on
accompagner les médecins traitants pour
qu'ils se saisissent davantage de cette
prérogative et par ailleurs
pourrait-elle être élargie l'information
sur les directives anticipées je vous
remercie merci
Madame Joël Melin
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
en tant que membre de la Commission de
la mission pas de la commission émission
remercier chaleureusement monsieur le
Président et les deux co-rapporteurs de
la qualité du travail je pense que nous
avons travaillé de manière extrêmement
au-delà du lacourtoisie de en profondeur
et je vous remercie du choix des
auditions concernant
l'évaluation puisqu'il s'agissait de là
de cela la loi classe Léonetti
manifestement a vu valider ses principes
que ce soit à la fin l'obstination des
raisonnable que ce soit les directives
anticipées la personne de confiance et
la sédation profonde continue jusqu'au
décès en revanche tout le monde l'a dit
l'application reste à désirer que ce
soit la connaissance à la fois des potes
de la part des patients mais ont-ils
envie de s'occuper de leur mort les
professionnels c'est beaucoup plus
gênant l'ambiguïté sur qui préside à la
désignation des directives anticipées de
la personne de confiance et puis bien
évidemment les manques de moyens
logistiques financiers humains ce qui a
abouti une perte de chance pour les
patients une gêne pour les soignants et
conditionne largement la perception de
la loi voire même une certaine confusion
le point central de la sédation pourrait
se résumer par quicon comment mais en
l'occurrence on ne peut pas le faire
sous cette forme on va dire quand qui
est comment si c'est quand comme la
rapporter Monsieur Martin dans les
délibres il y a pas de discussion à
avoir je pense ce sont les soignants
dans la continuité compassionelle qu'ils
ont à l'égard de leur patients qui vont
accompagner et comment par la sédation
profonde et continue dont on admet à un
moment donné qu'on la définit surtout si
elle doit être définitive il faudra
qu'elle soit précisé probablement dans
les décrets pour être la moins longue
possible et pouvoir faire sortir
l'alimentation et l'hydratation de la
notion de soins si elle est dans des
délais retardés ce qui se voit dans
certains cas particuliers de maladies
neurologiques ou de cancer il y a là la
nécessité de dire qu'il y a des enjeux
sociétaux et un risque de pénalisation
précisément des pénalisés par la loi
klest néonetti qui nous font dire qu'il
faut impérativement garder la loi
classée telle qu'elle est et permettre
surtout qu'il y a un texte totalement
différent qui soit ouvert à la
discussion c'est d'ailleurs le cas avec
le projet d'étude qui est le groupe
d'études qui est en place et pour nous
séparer et garder cette loi klestéonetti
en l'état merci bien Madame la députés
madame Justine Gruet merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
j'associe également mes remerciements à
tous les membres de cette mission dont
je faisais partie et vraiment pour la
sérénité dans laquelle on a pu débattre
d'un sujet aussi important
on nous en sommes au cinquième plan
grand plan soins palliatif j'aimerais
que si on amène un nouveau plan soins
palliatifs qu'on ne reproduise pas les
mêmes erreurs nous sommes toujours dans
l'attente aussi d'une loi grand âge
efficience efficiente et efficace pour
accompagner dignement nos seniors et je
crois que cela peut être complémentaire
je j'associerai mes propos sur la
culture palliative c'est important qu'on
soit en capacité à développer dans
l'ensemble des cursus de nos soignants
pour qu'elles deviennent aussi naturel
que les traitements curatifs qui qui
semblent prendre le pas dans les
formations de l'ensemble des soignants
et cette culture palliative doit
vraiment être présent à tout moment de
la vie à tout moment des traitements et
être complémentaires du curatif je ne
reviendrai pas sur la rémunération de la
T2A dans les établissements puisque vous
en avez parlé je m'interroge également
sur le développement dans les contrats
locaux de santé et dans les CPTs de
fiches actions de coordination des soins
palliatifs au plus près des territoires
parce qu'il me semble que ça n'est pas
non plus naturel dans le déploiement de
ses concepts administratifs je voulais
revenir également sur la simplification
administrative pour évaluer le GIR ça
m'a été remonté dans les auditions que
j'ai pu mener où on se retrouve encore
avec quelqu'un qui vient évaluer le GIR
d'une personne qui est en fin de vie et
alors c'est à la fois dur pour les
familles et complètement inutiles dans
le parcours et dans le cursus nous
médicalisons parfois beaucoup la
naissance il faut qu'on fasse attention
à ne pas hyper médicaliser la mort pour
mieux la maîtriser et enfin j'adresserai
tous mes remerciements pour la qualité
du travail de tous les professionnels
qui accompagnent des femmes et des
hommes au quotidien merci pour leur
grand-humanité il serait important de
parler des directives anticipées et de
la personne de confiance avec ses
proches et les soignants pour permettre
une fin de vie la plus digne possible
cette magnifique loi mérite tout
simplement d'être mieux connue merci
merci bien la parole est à Monique ibora
merci merci madame la Présidente tout de
suite en introduction je voudrais
insister sur le fait que la loi grand
âge n'a rien à voir avec la fin de vie
et que c'était tout le contraire et que
c'est tout le contraire donc je voulais
affirmer affirmer ceci puisque les soins
palliatifs peuvent bénéficier et
heureusement aussi à des gens qui sont
jeunes et qui sont pas forcément liés au
grand âge c'est la première chose que je
voulais préciser la deuxième chose c'est
que si j'ai bien compris en effet les
directives anticipées pratiquement non
ne sont pas appliqués puisque elles
n'existe pas avec les raisons qu'a donné
Didier Martin qu'on peut entendre et
qu'on pouvait d'ailleurs anticiper dès
2016 que d'autre part moi je vois pas
très bien comment s'exprime la volonté
du patient aujourd'hui dans les
possibilités de la sédation profonde et
continue puisque j'ai bien entendu c'est
relativement peu utilisé en tout cas ce
n'est même pas répertorié donc là on a
un vrai problème d'évaluation la
deuxième chose c'est là je m'adresse au
médecin parce que je ne suis pas
compétente forcément sur le sujet
cette sédation médicamenteuse parce que
c'est quand même ça est-ce qu'il y a une
grande différence entre la sédation
médicamenteuse au niveau des produits
utilisés quand on l'utilise pour la
sédation légère et temporaire ou est-ce
que ce sont les mêmes produits
médicamenteux il suffirait de pousser
plus loin ça veut dire que c'est un
problème de curseur et que ce curseur je
pense mais je me trompe peut-être parce
que je suis pas encore passé en soins
palliatifs je pense que ce curseur il
dépend essentiellement du médecin parce
que un malade qui a été en sédation
légère et temporaire il est déjà en
sédation est-ce que en effet il peut
faire Val sa volonté et finalement dire
maintenant j'arrête je veux arriver au
bout ce qui n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui sur on s'en tient à la
législation donc voilà tout ça il faut
quand même qu'on le règle je termineerai
en
ayant une pensée pour Olivier vallonie
qui lui est là pour jean-Louis Touraine
qui lui n'est pas là et sans doute
remercier le président qui a bien voulu
notre président qui a bien voulu
relancer le sujet quand même il faut
bien le dire pour le moment en tout cas
dans la sérénité merci très bien Madame
la Députée monsieur Cyril Isa
merci à la présidente monsieur le
Président chers amis rapporteur merci
pour ce travail et pour la présentation
de ce rapport d'évaluation de
l'application pratique de la loi
classionnettiste adoptée il y a 7 ans
qu'il faut le rater a été adopté à
l'unanimité étant le fruit d'un très
grand consensus
l'unanimité est votants
la
disparité donc vous faites trois
constats
dans votre rapport premièrement l'accès
est insatisfaisant notamment dans les
EHPAD comme la Rapée notre apporteur
Didier Martin les disparités sont très
fortes conduisant à ce que deux tiers
des malades nécessitant de politique
n'est pas accès ceci est inacceptable
deuxième constat les directives les
dispositifs de directives anticipées et
de personnes de confiance sont peu
utilisées mais comme le rappelait notre
apporteur car une Fiat qui d'entre nous
a rédigé ces directives anticipées ou
désigner sa personne de confiance
ceci peut être dû par un manque de
connaissances mais peut aussi venir du
sentiment d'être loin très loin de ce
sujet
enfin la sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès est également très plus
utilisée très difficile à mettre en
place à l'hôpital comme le rappelait
Olivier valorny par manque de moyens
mais aussi bon on peut penser par la
pratique à déterminer le moyen des potes
de mettre en place
la loi christianétique est à un
diablement constitué une avancée forte
pour les patients en et pour les et pour
les soignants en améliant les conditions
de prise en charge de fin de vie
celle-ci on constate état suffisamment
déployés je pense que aujourd'hui
ça doit être notre priorité la priorité
de notre conclusion et de notre
assemblée et je pense qu'il faut que
nous en prenions aujourd'hui pour que
lors des futurs lois de financement de
la civilisation sociale nous doutions
toutes les structures des moyens pour
ses droits comme il est président de la
loi à une fin de vie et accompagner du
meilleur apaisement possible à la
souffrance je vous remercie et
effectivement aussi une pensée pour
notre collègue Touraine et lui du
département du Rhône merci bien je me
permets juste d'intervenir dans ce débat
par rapport aux soins palliatifs si je
ne m'abuse dans le cas du bel effet SS
2022 il y a eu une enveloppe de 500
millions d'euros qui avait été
effectivement voté pour améliorer les
soins palliatifs effectivement ce serait
bien qu'on est un peu le retour et je
suis bien sûr bien consciente qu'il faut
aller plus loin et notamment au regard
de la discussion que nous avons ce matin
la parole à présent est à alors j'essaie
de dialoguer merci madame la Présidente
alors bien évidemment je salue à mon
tour le travail qui a accompli
les rapporteurs moi j'ai une question
alors attention un peu subsidiaire c'est
pas tant sur le fond mais je voulais
vous poser la question sur
l'acceptibilité l'acceptabilité pardon
de de la décision qu'on sera amené à
apprendre la décision les négative sur
un sujet aussi clivant et à ce sujet je
voulais avoir votre avis si vous voulez
bien me le donner
sur
sur un sujet donc je l'ai dit aussi
complexe et sensible que pensez-vous de
l'exercice de démocratie participative
menée par la Convention citoyenne
pilotée par le CESU est-ce que vous avez
pris connaissance de leur 67
propositions est-ce que et est-ce que
vous pensez qu'à un moment qui a eu des
conventions citoyennes qu'on peut
toujours donner des résultats très
probants mais est-ce que vous pensez
qu'à un moment la convention citoyenne
leur proposition et ses citoyens
pourront rejoindre vos propositions à
vous merci beaucoup merci la parole est
à Madame Astrid Panossian Bouvet merci
madame la Présidente en tant que membre
de cette mission je voulais vraiment
charleuse heureusement remercier le
président les rapporteurs également les
membres saluer la la sérénité mais aussi
la dignité de nos débats et je dois vous
avouer ma ma fierté d'avoir pu faire
partie de cette mission vraiment je
voulais vous remercier sincèrement
j'avais une question d'abord une
remarque par rapport à l'enveloppe de
500 millions d'euros qui a effectivement
été voté dans le PLFSS et une autre
remarque qui nous a été formulée par
Monsieur Léonetti et qui nous disait que
souvent et bien malgré ses fléchages et
bien une fois que la décision était
prise le soin palliatif était toujours
la dernière roue du carrosse parce que
quand il y a un fichage vers un hôpital
particulier il prenait l'exemple de
Marseille et bien la priorité va aller
aux urgences aux soins pédiatriques et
pas nécessairement aux soins palliatifs
et donc il y a clairement aussi une
améliorant amélioration à faire sur les
directives très précises et les
instructions très précises que donne le
ministre au président ou au Directeur
d'Agence régionale de santé sur cette
allocation d'enveloppe moi j'avais une
question plus précise sur une de nos
recommandations qui concerne finalement
la sédation adaptée en fonction de la
situation du patient
le sujet d'intentionnalité aussi que
vous avez posé comme étant un obstacle
parfois vécu par nos par nos soignants
sur cette question est-ce qu'il faut
dans le cadre de cette de cette loi
renforcer les protections juridiques de
nos soignants pour les conforter à la
fois sur cette question d'intentionalité
et sur cette capacité à pouvoir ensuite
adapter la sédation en fonction de la
situation du patient pour éviter des
situations prolongées qui qui sont
difficiles pour pour tout le monde merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur
Erica lozet merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais déjà vraiment remercier
chaleureusement nos trois collègues
d'avoir posé les bases de la réflexion
profonde qui nous attend maintenant ma
question après aux soins palliatifs nous
avons savons tous que nous devons
aborder ce débat sur la fin de vie de
l'aide activa mourir avec énormément de
précautions et dans le respect mutuel au
vu de la sensibilité du sujet des
convictions profondes des uns et des
autres
dans cette question on peut faire appel
à des références morales éthiques
religieuses cette approche
précautionnelle doit nous encourager à
ne surtout pas opposer des soins
palliatifs qui font l'objet de votre
rapport et de l'aide active à mourir que
nous devons sur laquelle nous devons
nous pencher ma question est donc la
suivante pouvez-vous nous donner votre
appréciation à la lueur de vos travaux
bien sûr sur le lien entre ces deux
objectifs plus précisément est-ce que
l'insuffisance de soins palliatifs
pourrait constituer une motivation
susceptible à conduire un recours à
l'aide active à mourir puisque c'est
l'une des critiques qu'on entend ce que
l'on entend souvent ou à l'inverse
l'aide active à mourir ne serait-elle
pas un levier du développement des soins
palliatifs ne serait-ce que pour eux
éviter que ne s'installe d'idée que
l'aide active à mourir viendrait
suppléer la supposer insuffisance de
soins palliatifs sommes-nous devant une
dualité ou au contraire une
potentialisation de ces deux réponses
est-ce que les exemples étrangers
peuvent éclairer cette question une
observation pour terminer une des
limites de la loi leetti tient aux
maladies dont l'issue fatale n'est pas à
court terme mais à moyen terme et je
pense en particulier aux maladies
neurologiques j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir un peu plus tard mais en tout
cas l'exigence c'est de se mettre à la
place du patient avant tout autre chose
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Mathieu marchaud
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues rapporteur je tiens à celui
votre travail quel que soit nos
approches sur un sujet aussi grave que
la fin de vie il est important de
débattre en croisant des analyses bien
documentées votre apport contribue à
cette qualité du débat la loi
nous sommes probablement plusieurs ici à
l'avoir expérimenté dans notre vie
familiale ce fut mon cas je suis donc
particulièrement intéressé aux volets
concernant les soins palliatifs vendredi
dernier je visitais une unité à Lille et
je voudrais remonter deux points le
premier c'est une qualité des soins et
de la prise en charge qui s'est
visiblement accrue par rapport au début
je peux également témoigner de quelques
avancées notables mais encore
insuffisantes dans le traitement à
domicile le second point comme le rappel
votre travail c'est que ces dispositifs
sont encore très largement sous
dimensionné par rapport aux besoins et
encore mal connu de nos concitoyens il
me semble donc prioritaire de développer
cette offre et l'information envers nos
concitoyens il est indispensable que
notre assemblée avance sur vos
proposition pour recruter des médecins
et pour revoir les financements ces
efforts sont prioritaires renforçant
l'existant et donnons véritablement des
moyens nécessaires pour appliquer une
loi leetti à la fois équilibré et
présentant des avancées considérables je
pense que mourir dans la dignité c'est
d'être accompagné jusqu'au bout avec
attention et respect envers la vie qui
s'en va si une société aussi riche que
la note n'est pas capable d'assurer cela
à ses membres alors tous nos principes
qu'ils soient républicains ou autre sont
vins à titre personnel je refuse que des
Français mal informés et inquiet de voir
des situations dramatiques autour de
déclare préféré avoir accès une mort
médicalisée par crainte d'être une
charge pour leurs proches voire même
d'être abandonné cette remarque est
maintenant d'une personne rencontrait en
circonscription m'a bouleversé et je
pense que nous sommes très nombreux à
l'entendre ici avant une rupture
radicale avec notre modèle de société
j'aimerais avoir plein d'autres
questions dont nous l'occasion de
débattre une question concrète comment
pensez-vous pouvoir renforcer
l'information de nos concitoyens merci
merci Monsieur Jean-François Rousset
merci madame la Présidente voilà moi je
voudrais témoigner d'abord remercier les
trois rapporteurs parce que j'ai
participé j'étais assez fier d'être
cette mission d'évaluation pour la
sincérité de leur rapport voilà
et c'est en parallèle de ce que j'ai
vécu dans ma circonscription puisque
j'ai participé à deux réunions pour
traiter de ces sujets ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que à mon avis il faut
tenir compte de la continuité des soins
il faut pas isoler les soins palliatifs
de des autres soins puisqu'il y a en
continuant très souvent
quand on parle de cancer mais quand on
parle aussi de handicap etc de maladie
neuro dégénératives donc
c'est un continuum mais il faut que les
gens qui en ont besoin puissent arriver
progressivement vers les soins
palliatifs et surtout soit pris en
charge tout le monde l'a dit
mais on s'aperçoit que dès qu'on aborde
ce sujet sous l'aspect de notre rôle qui
est celui de légiférer on va sentir des
tensions
on va vivre des tensions et moi je crois
que il faudra jamais oublier quand on
aura apprend des décisions qu'au milieu
il y a un homme ou une femme qui va
mourir et qu'il faut aider à mourir dans
la dignité et respecter ce qu'il a dit
au moment où il y a pu le dire sinon
faire confiance à la personne de
confiance et puis surtout considérer que
pour l'aider à passer cette étape il y a
d'un côté des soignants qui nous ont dit
moi que c'était difficile qu'il fallait
les protéger qu'il fallait les former
mais souvent quelqu'un qui a pris en
charge quelqu'un pendant longtemps c'est
souvent la personne la plus proche et
qui est la plus à même à apporter ses
soins de fin de vie et il y a une
certaine
c'est particulier mais c'est moi j'ai
rencontré soignant qui était assez
satisfait d'aller jusqu'au bout de leurs
souhaits c'est un service à rendre qui
était un échec par rapport à au but
thérapeutique mais que voilà donc ça ça
existe aussi et d'un autre côté il y a
les familles les familles qu'il faudra
prendre en charge bien sûr parce que
trop souvent elles sont mises devant des
réalités et elle se répartie un petit
peu de la décision d'où l'intérêt de
faire travailler tout le monde en
collégialité voilà très bien merci
Monsieur Paul Christophe
oui merci mais la présidente à mon tour
je tiens à saluer le travail de nos
rapporteurs mais on doutait pas de leurs
compétences et de leur volonté de
s'investir sur le sujet c'est l'occasion
également de rendre hommage aux
soignants qui exercent un service ou un
palatif alors je pense en particulier à
ces femmes et ses hommes qui travaillent
sur l'hôpital maritime de zuydcote mais
la commune de résidence c'est un hôpital
que je connais bien
paradoxalement d'ailleurs pour parfois
échanger avec les soignants ils nous
font et les familles ils nous font
témoigner nous témoignent de finalement
d'un retour à la vie en accompagnant la
fin de vie alors il exprime qu'il
reprenne goût finalement à la vie
lorsqu'ils accompagnent un patient en
fin de vie donc démonstration de
l'utilité également de ses services j'ai
même le souvenir d'avoir célébrer un
mariage au sein de l'unité de soins
palliatifs de zuycottes une émotion
sincère et rage je peux en témoigner axe
insuffisant des tous d'accord manque
d'information sur les directives
anticipées sur les témoignages les
témoins de confiance on l'a dit
malheureusement c'est c'est une un
constat qu'on fait souvent sur nos
politiques
on voit que le aller vers la question de
la bonne information et finalement de
l'accès aux droits que que nous ouvrons
par nos textes et souvent malmené quel
est selon vous la bonne méthode
finalement pour faire en sorte que et
bien nos concitoyens soient mieux
informés finalement ils ont fini soient
mieux accompagné et mieux guider dans
leur choix même s'il nous reste
peut-être à faire évoluer à cette
question du choix mais ce sera et bien
évidemment d'autres débats auxquels nous
ne manqueront pas merci bien et bien je
vais passer la parole à nos rapporteur
oui alors Monsieur Didier Martin
merci beaucoup chers collègues j'ai pris
quelques notes tout d'abord
la déclaration rapportée de Monsieur
Jean Leonetti 12% des malades hurlent de
douleur moi j'ai travaillé en centre
hospitalier périphérique j'ai travaillé
en CHU j'ai travaillé en
à Paris aussi
j'ai travaillé en radiologie j'ai
travaillé différentes circonstances en
centre de lutte contre le cancer
j'ai jamais entendu les patients hurler
de douleur
si tel était le cas il faudrait quand
même se poser de grave question alors
j'aime bien cette citation de Monsieur
le Nettier ont la même mis comme un
titre tabloïde au début de notre rapport
mais
au secours quoi au secours heureusement
que ce n'est pas une réalité quotidienne
alors il y a des cris d'appel ils sont
entendus il y a des évaluations de la
douleur tout le personnel est chargé
d'évaluer la douleur et il faut alors il
y a d'autres types de douleurs peut-être
la douleur psychique il y a peut-être la
douleur morale il y a peut-être la
douleur sociétale mais qu'il faut
traiter aussi dans un accompagnement
mais moi j'ai pas travaillé dans les
mêmes hôpitaux que que ceux qui seraient
décrits
à Madame béret
madame la député je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le rôle du médecin
traitant et d'autres collègues abordé
aussi sur l'élaboration des directives
anticipées dans le cadre des discussions
anticipées ces discussions il faut du
temps pour prendre du temps
c'est pas toujours ce que les soignants
ont
en plus créer cet espace de de
verbalisation
bienveillante un mode de communication
en dehors et en parallèle du combat
contre la maladie ça c'est le bon climat
dans lequel on discute et on peut amener
à
recueillir des directives anticipées par
voie orale ou par voie écrite et se
faire en tant que personne de confiance
en tant que soignant une véritable
conviction de ce que veut le patient et
de ce qu'il voulait parce que les
directives anticipées c'est plus
impatient qui parle c'est un patient qui
ne peut plus en état en capacité de
parler
je suis d'accord on garde la classe
unité en état sauf qu'on a deux petits
amendements en potentiel sur classé Audi
le rapport d'évaluation tous les deux
ans et l'adaptation de la sédation en
fonction des circonstances on s'est mis
d'accord sur ce point-là parce que c'est
la vérité c'est ce qui se passe pour
Madame Gruet chers collègues oui je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous sur la
coordination elle est très importante
elle nécessite aussi du temps et elle
nécessite aussi de la bonne volonté
qu'on peut trouver dans certains CPTs
globalement la réflexion que je voulais
partager c'est que les soins palliatifs
aujourd'hui sont trop trop hospitalo
centré et qu'il s'il faut apporter des
moyens des remèdes il faut sortir de
cette hospitalocentrisme concernant les
soins padiés madame ibora oui que ce
soit une sédation légère une sédation
profonde c'est production de doses il y
a juste certains produits qui sont des
produits de type anesthésique là qui
sont tout à fait radicaux le propofol en
particulier et puis les curare là on
arrête de respirer et on perd confiance
et c'est effectivement fatale on serait
dans une injection létale mais les
drogues sédatifs adaptés le midazole
avant particulier c'est une question de
dose et quand on allège les doses le
patient se réveille ça permet pour des
sédations temporaires de d'évaluer la
douleur l'état de de conscience etc
c'est une pratique délicate mais comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il y a
plusieurs types de sédation la sédation
profonde continue est un acte comme l'a
dit Olivier qui se veut définitif enfin
une dans les conséquences seront
définitives sans marche arrière mais on
sait qu'il faut adapter cette cession
pour les manques de moyens je crois
avoir répondu la démocratie
participative de Monsieur le gag 100%
d'accord je crois que il ne c'est sur
cette question de la fin de vie comme
l'a dit Agnès Firma le Baudot qui
travaille beaucoup sur les soins
palliatifs il faut de l'humidité
il faut de l'humanité et il faut
conduire des choses de façon
démocratique dans le cas parce que c'est
la vraie débat sociétal ça nous oriente
ça nous oriente sur la reconnaissance de
certaines libertés certaines volontés
individuelles ça nous oriente aussi sur
notre devoir de solidarité qui a des
grands principes de notre système de
santé
sur l'argent j'ai dit ce que j'en
pensais
ça s'améliore c'est pas mal sur
l'intention alors là moi je rentre pas
là dessus c'est pour ça que ma
proposition d'amendement sur la sédation
profonde qu'on ait du adapté
je ne pense pas je pense que il est
important que la loi soit et des creux
et des vides
parce que si on commence à dire que
quand on modifie les doses c'est pour
provoquer la mort ça n'ira pas donc on
adapte et on discute de façon collégiale
et on ne précise pas l'intentionnalité
je ne suis pas juré je ne suis pas juge
mais je ne voudrais pas
je ne voudrais pas aller sur ce terrain
là de l'intentionalité parce que on
passe effectivement dans un autre
registre plus juridique
monsieur à Lausanne oppose le cas des
maladies neurologiques court terme moyen
terme
effectivement moi je suis assez
affirmatif mes collègues diront ce
qu'ils veulent
cleationnetti c'est pour le court terme
pour le très court terme c'est ça qui
est prévu et ces outils c'est des moyens
des obligations mais c'est pour le très
court terme les maladies qui vont
emporter dans six mois dans trois mois
on n'est pas dans le cadre de
la loi à mon sens voilà et puis là
encore personnellement l'insuffisance
des soins palliatifs ne doit pas nous
conduire à proposer un texte sur l'aide
d'active à mourir non il faut absolument
nous l'avons dit donnons les pistes il
nous faut renforcer les moyens
attribués aux soins palliatifs
et
pour Monsieur Marcio
oui l'information comment informer
je reviens à cette idée de proximité
parce que les campagnes grand public on
les connaît quoi on en a même certaines
parfois financer dans des domaines très
divers des variés j'ai fait ça ça coûte
très cher c'est 8 jours de d'affichage
etc et puis après les gens passent à
autre chose parce que voilà c'est ça la
société donc moi je miserai plutôt sur
la relation de proximité avec le médecin
traitant avec l'IDE qui passe à domicile
qui prend le temps et il faudra
valoriser ce temps il faudra le prendre
en compte parce que ça nous a été dit
par Monsieur Herman mbongo qui est
infirmier libéral dans le sud de
l'Essonne il nous dit il y a une
question de rémunération il y a une
question du temps soignant c'est pas du
paiement à l'acte c'est effectivement un
acte mais c'est dans sa globalité il
nous faudra une cotation adaptée et
sortir de des schémas actuels
si on veut effectivement que ce soit
efficace et surtout voilà
pour Monsieur Rousset merci beaucoup de
d'avoir pensé aux familles aussi
et d'avoir souligné ce continuum ce
relais n'ont pas de points mais en amont
ce tuilage entre la démarche curative et
la démarche palliative et puis
j'ai beaucoup apprécié
monsieur Christophe qui parlait d'un
mariage en face du moi aussi ça m'est
arrivé d'aller dans un établissement
d'hospitalisation pour célébrer un
mariage c'est ce que je voulais dire
tout à l'heure
en très difficile de parler de la mort
mais on peut parler de la vie y compris
deux jours avant le décès
et donc de l'amour et de la tendresse je
vous remercie
merci bien madame Fiat oui
effectivement il y a eu beaucoup de
questions
beurette sur l'investissement des
médecins traitants
dans le choix de la personne de
confiance et dans les discussions
anticipées
on enlève tous mais quand vous on écoute
le médecin traitant il nous explique
déjà tout ce qu'ils peuvent plus prendre
de nouvelles patientèle et que le temps
de consultation devient de plus en plus
court donc ça devient compliqué pour eux
de faire ce dont je pense ils auraient
très envie de faire
concernant la sédation moins longue
possible c'était madame Melin qui posait
la question
oui mais le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas on peut pas deviner et ça c'est les
médecins il y a une décision collégiale
on se dit la personne étant fin de vie
ces derniers heures jours mais on a
encore pas un bouton sur notre corps
humain qui nous prévient que
notre notre donc évidemment on espère
tous que ce soit le moins long possible
mais vous avez aussi des corps ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure qui résiste plus
à l'envie de vivre que de mourir
madame la députée gruée sur la culture
palliatifs complémentaire à la culture
curative et moi enfin ça a été relevé
dans toutes les auditions je posais la
question mais quand le jour où on
formera nos soignants et surtout les
médecins à ne plus guérir mais à soigner
je pense que nous aurons progressé dans
cette culture palliative parce que non
la mort n'est pas un échec la mort c'est
c'est la vie parce que
au grand étonnement général de tout le
monde nous allons tous mourir donc
autant que ce soit dans les meilleures
conditions et ça en revient madame
panossion Bouvet sur le fléchage soins
palliatif vers d'autres services
voilà mais quand vous voulez guérir et
ben vous mettez pas les soins dans le
palliatif et quand même vraiment dommage
madame
ibora merci d'avoir bien précisé
qu'effectivement le grand âge si on
pouvait éviter de d'expliquer que le
grand âge c'est obligatoirement la mort
ce serait une bonne idée
et d'autant plus que l'exemple qui nous
a le plus vraiment moi traumatisé c'est
se nourrisson on meurt à tout âge et
non ce n'est pas une histoire de
personne âgées et si je pouvais passer
un message s'il y a des gens qui nous
écoutent alors effectivement anticipées
ce n'est pas une obligation mais enfin
c'est encore moins une obligation
d'attendre d'être malade pour les
remplir ou d'attendre des trajets pour
les remplir ou voilà non mais c'est
c'est dès que c'est quand c'est fait et
en plus on peut les changer les modifier
autant de fois qu'on veut c'est comme la
personne de confiance je fais ma
formation là voilà autant le faire si
vous le souhaitez n'attendons pas d'être
malade
du coup on vous a répondu sur la
sédation moi je rajouterais quand même
sur la sédation temporaire c'est parfois
une demande des patients eux-mêmes moi
je suis à le vivre ou ils savent que le
fils qui habite au Canada va arriver et
va être conscient quand l'enfant
arrivera et du coup c'est une demande
que ce soit pas trop d'oser pour pouvoir
avoir cet échange et à ça aussi qui peut
arriver
monsieur le gars qui serait
l'acceptabilité du législateur
par rapport à un autre texte et la
convention citoyenne
j'ai bien envie de penser que tous les
législateurs vont accepter les décisions
de la convention citoyenne parce que
sinon je pense que on parlera pas de la
convention citoyenne sur
plus de l'écologie enfin je sais plus le
terme le climat ou tout est propositions
n'ont pas été reprise et ça a été
vraiment très compliqué dans la
population donc effectivement
nous lirons avec intention attention
leur
texte et sur
monsieur alosé l'appréciation sur
l'absence de soins palliatifs amène à
l'aide un besoin d'active à mourir je ne
le pense pas je vais répéter ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure mais il ne faut pas
opposer les deux et il ne faut pas
opposer un texte qui s'occupe des gens
qui vont mourir dans les quelques heures
un texte des gens des personnes qui
souhaitent mourir et Paul Christophe la
bonne méthode pour mieux informer nos
citoyens
mettons nous y tous c'est bon mettons
nous y tous levons tous nos manches et
parlons à tout le monde et expliquons
que non la mort c'est pas tabou
changeons la vision de la société face à
la mort et ça ira beaucoup mieux
tu le président merci madame la
Présidente beaucoup de beaucoup de
réponses ont été apportées je me
permettrai de de répondre en remercions
les autres collègues pour pour l'hommage
rendu à notre travail
revenir sur quatre points très vite
d'abord Monique oui
il serait vraiment
il n'est pas il n'est pas normal et il
n'est pas possible de confondre fin de
vie et grand âge alors l'expression fin
de vie effectivement peut être ambigu
parce que on peut dire bah oui moi j'ai
mes deux grands-mères et me dit je suis
en fin de vie mais nous traitons de la
fin de vie nous parlons de gens malades
et la vieillesse n'est pas une maladie
voilà donc nous parlons de gens malades
et malheureusement on peut être malade à
tout âge donc confondre grand âge et fin
de vie en tout cas dans la face sur la
façon dont nous travaillons c'est à dire
soit un palliatifs directives anticipé
sédation profonde et continue nous
parlons de gens malades et
malheureusement dont le pronostic vital
est irréversible donc ne confondons pas
les deux
et je vois bien parfois que certains
veulent nous entraîner dans cette
confusion qui n'a pas lieu d'être
merci Monique de le rappeler deuxième
point sur la question juridique évoquée
Astrid
la question de l'accès à la sédation
profonde et continue pose aussi un
problème sur le plan effectivement
juridique et le Conseil constitutionnel
a été appelé à trancher parce que la loi
précise effectivement
renforce le caractère contraignant des
directives anticipées mais elles sont
contraignantes mais pas opposables c'est
à dire que le médecin peut estimer que
ces directives sont inappropriées dans
un sens comme dans l'autre d'ailleurs
certains médecins peuvent estimer que la
sédation profonde et continuée
nécessaire alors que le malade dans ces
directives anticipées a dit je veux
vivre jusqu'au bout et ce cas s'est
présenté c'est rare honnêtement les
directives anticipées qui disent moi je
veux vivre jusqu'au bout quel qu'en soit
les conséquences et ne pas être endormi
c'est arrivé et c'est arrivé et donc il
y a eu conflit
conflit décision contradictoire puisque
le médical disait si on ne plonge pas
cette personne dans une sédation
profonde et continue on fait de
l'obstination des raisonnables
contrairement à la ville du malade et le
Conseil constitutionnel a confirmé la
décision des médecins
en disant effectivement si les médecins
considèrent que la demande du malade est
inappropriée et bien il peut s'opposer à
la directive anticipée donc la décision
de sédation profonde a été confirmée
malgré la vie du malade
cas très rare mais en l'occurrence ce
Conseil constitutionnel a été saisi
sur sur la question de Didier sur la
convention citoyenne je le dis d'autant
plus facilement que moi j'étais
sceptique
je vous dis sincèrement quand le
président de la République a dit je vais
faire une convention citoyenne sur la
fin de vie
je
l'ai dit d'abord j'espère que c'est pas
une manière une façon de procrastiner
et ensuite
une convention ça oblige ça oblige
d'autant plus dans le contexte actuel où
il y a un besoin de d'écouter les
Français donc j'étais sceptique
et je dois avouer que mon scepticisme
c'est totalement envolé
non pas sur les résultats mais sur la
façon dont les travaux étaient menés
puisque les résultats nous les avons pas
nous les aurons dimanche
et je dois saluer parce que ce travail a
été contesté alors vous savez c'est le
problème de la démocratie quand vous
faites des votes et que le vote ne
correspond pas à ce que vous souhaitez
et bien soit on vous demande de changer
le peuple soit on critique la façon dont
ça a été mené donc que quatre cinq
personnes sur 185 soit mécontente et à y
dire après à l'extérieur que ça a pas
été bien mené bon bah ça peut arriver
pour autant le travail du Conseil
économique social et environnemental a
été remarquable et le travail des
conventionnelles des citoyens qui sont
venus pendant 8 ou 9 weekends a été
absolument remarquable donc cette
convention moyenne contrairement à ce
que je pensais elle est je pense très
utile très utile après
quand fera le président de la République
il a voulu voilà moi j'espère à titre
personnel qui l'entendra la première
ministre avait posé une question très
claire
très très clair c'est peut-être la
différence avec la Convention sur le
climat ou il y avait beaucoup trop de
sujets beaucoup trop de sujets donc il y
avait une question très claire qui était
posée nous aurons la réponse dimanche
donc vraiment je veux saluer la
convention citoyenne et je pense que
c'est aussi une occasion de montrer ce
que peut être la démocratie
participative s'articulant avec la
démocratie parlementaire que nous
faisons vivre aujourd'hui dernière
question celle de Eric à l'Osée
sur sur l'opposition soins palliatif et
d'active à mourir bon tu connais ma
position cette opposition je ne la fais
pas
donc je rentre pas dans parce que c'est
pas l'objet du jour en revanche je donne
un constat
qui a été fait par
la ministre Agnès Firmin le Baudot en
audition
et qui nous a dit puisqu'elle s'est
déplacée dans de nombreux pays que nulle
part ou l'aide active à mourir avait été
instauré nulle part on avait mesuré une
baisse du nombre de lit en soins
palliatifs mais au contraire l'inverse
voilà donc je mets ça au débat c'est un
constat chiffré quantitatif qui
sort de enfin voilà qui qui est
quantitatif et qui n'est pas contestable
après chacun tirera les conclusions
qu'il veut
merci bien bon il ne me reste plus qu'à
m'entourer également donc de remercier
féliciter nos rapporteurs et le
président donc de cette mission ainsi
que l'ensemble des des membres de la
mission je salue également la sérénité
dans dans laquelle les débats se sont
déroulés effectivement ça fait du bien
alors je pense que connaître la réponse
mais donc je vous demande toutefois
l'autorisation donc de publier ce
rapport de grande qualité donc vous en
êtes toutes et tous d'accord très